mais là franchement j'adore ça mais pas
pour d'autres
parce que dit il ont ils ont changé nous
il a été viré m le pen s'appelle madame
le pen il est président d'honneur
monsieur je suis en pleine forme d'apéro
expliquer ses propos parce que je pense
même on oublier la question c'est de
savoir si on parle rassemblement
national pouvait être au pouvoir
marine exactement nouvelle présidente
moi je vous dire pourquoi je ne le crois
pas parce qu'il ya un double problème
qui n'a rien avec la politique est un
problème génétique et un problème c'est
sarkologies génétique c'est la marque le
pen et c'est nous les racistes la marque
le pen je parle la marque le pen je
parle de génétique au sens de la marche
j'ai écrit un bouquin là dessus je vous
l'avais non mais là c'est l'humoriste
jours mais ciaran alors même pareil je
fais c'est 90 arguments rei jaurena avec
génétique tout le monde aurait volé avec
le même c'est ce qu'on appelle le boulet
en politique qui aurait été un boulet
ses fourneaux des années alors vous êtes
démocrate où l'avidité
alors laissez moi juste parler donc la
marque c'est le boulet et pendant des
années l'objectif de marine le pen
c'était de faire oublier cette marque
elle n'a pas mené de diaboliser front
national en l'appelant rassemblement
national la dea lepénisé puisqu'elle est
c'est de la bombe
rassemblement national et après il
ouvrira sur le mans à cela ces
rassemblements bleu marine
donc est la même marie lise et mais
n'oublions pas évidemment que c'est la
fille jean-marie le pen et que la marque
le pen c'est que ça condamne ouais comme
une forme de malédiction le
rassemblement national à ne jamais être
élu tant que le pen ou une le pen en
sera la présidente ou le même temps
leurs maris chasser alors justement je
vais venir si les uns souhaitent une
génération
comment psychogénéalogie vous le savez
j'ai entendu on a fait six milliards là
dessus ça saute une génération c'est la
deuxième génération
marion maréchal s'appelle marion
maréchal le pen a été gommée même par la
presse bel arrêt et weir et il y est
donc cet argument là qui est très
important donc la marque le pen joue en
un qui sait quoi là dans l'adn de la
marque le pen c'est quoi c'est pas
présider c'est provoquer et en 2002 on
l'a vu c'est une très mauvaise nouvelle
contrairement à ce qu'on pense pour jean
marie le pen parce qu'il n'avait jamais
pensé est au second tour il était là
pour provoquer est l'agitateur
l'on se retrouver en posture de
présidentialisation c'est quelque part
tu es son adn de provocateur parce
qu'être président c'est pas provoquer
demandé à coluche en 80 ans quand il a
compris qu'il était à 16% d'intentions
de vote
il s'arrêtait d'être drôle il a vite
reculé ça c'est première arguments de
servir harriman oui de combien
c'est vrai ça le deuxième c'est psy
c'est qu'elle n'a pas envie d'être
présidente ça ce suspense
elle n'a jamais eu le désir comment
peut-on avoir une migraine le jour d'un
discours le jour d'un débarras tendance
à se décider
cette sicav élites issues du pouvoir oui
elle ne veut pas et les le pen ne
veulent pas président et donc les le pen
ne sont jamais président mais je suis
une petite fille ils ne sont jamais
président c'est mon opinion arrêtez donc
en fait ce que j'appelle et ça c'est
quand même voilà une petite pique [ __ ]
c'est la double peine
le pen c'est la double peine
eh oui non mais ça c'est un disque non
c'est un deal c'est un discours
absolument pour moi scandaleux parce que
d'abord ma si c'est du lard rivaliser
cicatriser l'adversaire et et parlait au
nom de l'ag d'une génétique mais vous
vous rendez compte de ce que vous dites
fallait téléspectateurs je me rends
compte mais vous je suis d'accord mais
enfin c'est quand même c'est quand même
ça mais dire dire qu'il ya une espèce de
génétique expliquerait des choses dira
qu' il ya une espèce de psychiatrie qui
expliquerait des postures non mais
attendez
voilà c'est l'union soviétique c'est
brejnev j'ai nettoyé génétique cette
opération génétique vous n'êtes pas vous
n'êtes pas le pas le fils de votre papa
on ne porte pas le même nom c'est une
insulte non à quoi merci on ne peut pas
décemment pas dire que c'est comme mon
père si c'est pas un loisir ça veut dire
mais c'est mon père je n'aime pas ça
veut dire ça veut dire que si mon père
est excessif mais au moins ce que je dis
cela veut dire que c'est identique c'est
simple si kia si mon père était si beau
père est intéressé c'est mon père était
criminelle delière moi ça me
prédestinait un criminel de guerre serbe
et dans ce cas là si van hamme
c'est toute la malbaie j'assume
dans un loft tous les deux et on ne sait
jamais je rajoute un truc je vous
rappelle quand même parce que vous dites
que c'est une marque c'est une marque
certes d'humains
c'est une marque qui vous plaît pas
probablement jezzy terme anglais c'est
une marque c'est une marque qui a quand
même représenté depuis 50 ans la boue et
sur laquelle se sont accrochés les
classes populaires françaises
valait 1 visibiliser par tout un système
qui a considéré froid qui a considéré
qu'il fallait faire disparaître les
classes populaires françaises qu'il
fallait gommer leur identité nationale
et les remplacer par des nouveaux venus
considéré comme une des vaches sacrées
jean bientôt pour une fille des
générations entières et des millions de
françaises aient définitivement la
marque front national a été la boue et
sur laquelle ils se sont accrochés bomba
disparaît au froid dans les océans
glacés de la mondialisation au froid
dans la fosse et genre